Thanks.
When we talk about burn out we talk about
three things and we don't always clarify what
we're talking about, we use it kind of interchangeably.
So the first is depression.
If you are depressed that's a medical problem
that requires medical help, I'm not a medical
professional and I'll give you no advice on
this topic.
The second thing is straight up over work.
You can't work constantly.
Everything we know about 80 hour work weeks
says that why we're not working them when
we think they're and two they're not sustainable.
I really like this, you get sent to Bora Bora
if you work too much.
The third thing is what I want to talk about
today, we expect and ask more of are jobs
than we get from them, so there is this gap
of what we need and what we have and if it
goes on for too long, or it gets too large,
that's when we start to feel burnt out.
You know, I often think that these things
can to go, write, like I know for myself,
being creative is so much a part of being
happy, burn out, depression, where does one
begin and the other one end, they're distinct
problems.
A few years ago I moved to Australia to run
an iOS team, we went to, it was started before
I arrived within six months, I kept my hours
45 a week, I would still come home on Friday
night and feel like my brain had bled out
through my eyes.
Then it was done and you know, they would
like this guy is going to ship next month,
go and help him, he didn't ship next month,
or the month after.
In fact I think it was about eight months
later.
It was really hard from running my own little
team to working on a project that wasn't really
running effectively.
In this position where like I had no influence
over making that better.
Add to this like the super miserable experience
of being harassed at work and the awful HR
process that ensued, I was in a really bad
place emotionally and my job was just like
not fulfilling.
So I tried to double down on my career, I'll
just work on Saturdays, I just need to work
harder, I'm going to do a side project.
So I started doing a side project and then
there was a reorganisation and it was clear
that the side project was never going to launch
either, I realised that what I needed was
to ship, that's what I missed.
The answer was not internal side projects,
but my own personal side project.
As an extra thing I had to - I think this
was the worst manager I ever had, he explained
to me that he believed by never giving me
positive feedback he was training me not to
need any .
If anyone is contemplating this, it doesn't
work!
So, as I shifted my focus to external
projects I got some much needed positive feedback
as well.
So, it turns out that this was not an entirely,
like, random realisation and I didn't invent
anything here.
There are six main causes of professional
burn out, the Maslach burn out, there is an
inventory and a book associated with it called
'The truth about burn out' the first one is
lack of control, that sounds familiar, hey!
Wait, then the next one, in sufficient reward,
also familiar.
Lack of community.
I went through this list and I'm like, Huh,
you know, this was the first project in a
while that I'd been on where I was the only
woman on the team and there were a number
of reasons why I felt very lonely but that
was one of them.
The fourth, absence of fairness.
Yeah, you know I've been successful and like
the result was that I ended up in a place
where I felt like I couldn't succeed.
The fifth is conflict in values.
You know, I value execution on a product.
The team, they like decided that what they
should be doing is replying a platform to
build their project on, obviously I disagree
with that, but this not a talk about poor
engineering decisions, that would need way
more than 25 minutes!
The 6th is work overload.
I look at this list and like these are all
problems we could use side projects to help
with except for number 6, yeah, it would probably
hurt with number 6, I do see that.
It's really hard to think of a side project
when you are feeling, you know, a bit dead
inside.
It's really hard to think that you have anything
to offer anybody else's side project when
the people that you work with day-to-day don't
seem to appreciate what you do.
My solution was to go back to my most recently
abandoned side project, we all have one, right.
So, I had this idea that, like, you know when
you look on your photographs on flickr or
whatever I thought it would be cool to visualise
a photograph stream just pulling out the dominant
colours from them, so the cool whites of Iceland,
lush green of Bali, the like orange and red
of Canadian Fall, it would tell it's only
story in a abstract way.
So I got so far as this layout, this is the
most efficient way to layout circles, it's
called a sunflower layout, so I just was tainting
the RGB value and in the one on the right
I just made it very close together, I kind
of like this, I imagine if I was to time travel
it would jump through something like that.
The next step was to pull the dominant colour
out of a photograph, like if someone solved
this the internet will help me.
The internet failed me.
But it did provide some interesting information,
image is array of pixels, a pixel is a square
of colour, there is a colour space all the
HSV space, the HSV is actually a lot closer
to the way we think about colour, so the different
colours go round in the circle and those are
the hue, the saturation, that we might think
about as intensity is the diameter and then
the high is brightness.
So at the bottom everything is black.
So, I was like, ok, you know, count the pixels,
check the colour.
Put them in buckets and, you know, we'll have
that dominant colour.
It will be fine.
This totally worked, but it turns out that
the dominant colour is often a little bit
sludgy, so the dominant colour on the left
that's the dominant colour extracted from
the image.
So I'm making these test images to see what
happens, I would only show things in a certain
range of the dominant colour, I started making
the cool partially coloured images and I could
see better what was going on.
So I made my visualisation, here it is.
It wasn't quite as incredible as I had imagined,
you know, it also took a really long time
to like, at least 30 minutes to calculate
these right.
One of the things that I discovered is that
for different images like, you need different
settings to really kind of capture what I
would perceive as the dominant colour, which
kind of makes sense, right, the way we perceive
things, we abstract things, summarise things,
dominant colour is largely a matter of perception,
but I considered this to be the completion
of a successful side project, you know.
I moved on to other things.
Then I got asked to write a book chapter,
I was like, oh well, I guess I wrote this
algorithm, so I could write a book chapter.
So I made it into a little photograph, Ited
all of this in processing, by the way, whilst
doing that I tried to put it online.
I used processing Java, not processing JavaScript,
I'm sorry, I know it's a JavaScript conference.
As I started trying to put this online, I
started trying to run into things, I didn't
want to deal - cross site describing permissions
and stuff, at some point on this journey,
I remembered I'm an expert mobile developer,
I was like Cate Huston why are you building
a mediocre desktop only app, clearly it should
be a web app, I started working, it got a
working prototype, I ran into terrible performance
problems, then I ended up creating a library
for testing, for generating and comparing
images on iOS, I ended up - you heard that
correctly, I optimised it for space and Time
Out side of the context of a technical interview,
it does occasionally happen.
The app is called show and hide, it will be
out pretty soon, I located to the UK, quit
the job I hated and started working for myself,
this kind of remains my side project, the
definition of side project is the things you
do for love not money.
Let's go back to that list.
Because now I had control.
Sometimes too much control, but like I definitely
have control.
Reward, people started to appreciate my work.
It was tied to other things I did at the same
time but till you know, I got much more positive
feedback from the community than I ever did
from that terrible manager.
Community, I had editors and support on the
book chapter, I work with a designer and a
branding person.
Fairness, proceeds from the book go to charity,
indie apps don't really make money I am excited
to get same share of nothing as everyone else
values so the kind of project I
burnt out on
it was like an enormous yak shaving project,
I did shave a lot of yaks in this process,
but everyone of them filled a need, I was
able to share that outcome with other people.
So from this testing library I made, building
a toolkit at workshop out of techniques I
used for doing really good test coverage on
iOS, getting the processing time down from
round like 10 seconds to instant, you know,
I solve actual problems not like made up engineer
problems.
There's an elephant in the room here and it's
name is time.
Right?
We only have 24 hours in the day 168 hours
in the week, some of us have a bunch of responsibilities
that others don't I am not going to tell you,
you could make time if you try harder.
There's things like rescue time that can be
honest with useful about how you are spending
you time, I am not going to tell you to stop
watching TV either, I am always baffled by
the talks that say work all day, top watching
TV, come home work all evening everything
will be fine.
you know I have never been watching
TV all evening, doesn't mean I don't have
unlimited hours to work right.
I also just don't think that's sustainable.
I am going to make two suggestions.
So firstly, are you doing stuff that you could
just not do?
For me, as a woman working in tech I ended
up doing a bunch of stuff that thank less
emotional labour basically.
A lot of it was round trying to improve the
representation of women.
Ladies, we don't have to do this.
giving this up freed up a lot of
time.
I cannot even tell you because I think that
stuff that you do is not generally valued
is a great place to start looking for things
you can not do and free up time.
I get that you wouldn't do it if you didn't
think it was important, like that was me too,
but you can make a choice to prioritise what
makes you happier over what you think you
should be doing, but nobody else is going
to.
We know that women leave tech at a much greater
rate than men.
The best thing that any of us can do is be
happy and fulfilled in our careers.
Secondly different kinds of time allow for
different kinds of progress, and so if you
use the time when you feel on top of your
game really well, then you can set yourself
up to achieve things when you are feeling
kind of meh.
If you have test that you need to write if
you spec them out when you are really on top
of things you can write them later when you
are feeling a bit like, life is hard.
Maybe even when you are watching TV offer
boiler plate your code whenever you are half
asleep on a Saturday morning, kind of fix
it, hook it up later in the day.
I often start with something I consider to
be a warm up task if I am not really feeling
like super productive and sometimes that then
when I get done, sometimes it turns into a
little spiral and I build on it.
The thought I want you to take away today
is a question.
What if you expected more from your side projects
and less from your job?
If our side projects, ooh, what does your
human need?
If our side projects involve other people,
how can we give them what they need?
It's worth asking someone, what do you want
to get out of this project because they might
tell you, but we have this handy list we can
refer back and to see if we're maybe meeting
people's needs on that.
So control.
Control is super easy if you just own something,
but I think control is being able to influence
the outcome.
You don't have to be in
charge, you just need to feel like you can
make a difference.
If we want to give people control we have
to give up a little bit ourselves and we have
to trust them and this is really hard, right?
We have to accept a little bit of chaos.
Reward, there's this book called the 5 Love
Languages which seems like a bizarre thing
to mention in this context, it's the best
book I found that understands that different
people appreciate different kinds of appreciation.
One of them is touch and just ignore that
one, touch is never an appropriate way to
reward someone in a professional context.
The other ones are words, you can
tell people they did it great job.
Gifts, now these don't have to be big, you
know like oh I found this e-book that I thought
you might like.
Time, you know, mentoring people.
Acts of service, and again this can be really
small like you are you are co-working you
make a point to make them a cup of tea.
Reward is what makes people feel like their
contribution is appreciated.
Whatever that is.
Community connection to other humans.
I think it's worth building healthy communities
on its own account, but let's just set that
aside for a moment because people will bond
together over a common enemy, this a short-term
and not a long-term strategy.
One thing we're seeing in open source right
now, is some projects are really investing
in their communities.
They are ramping up newbies, adding codes
of conduct, and we see others doubling down
on this fantasy of a meritocracy.
We will see in the long-term.
Fairness treating people equitably, can you
be transparent so it's clear what been rewarded
and why.
Can you work to remove bias.
Because we know in this industry that we have
a problem with the way that we treat women
and the way that we treat minorities.
We get this shit at work, I got called the
C word by a colleague amongst other things,
and it was horrible, but I put up with this
stuff day today because they paid me really
well to do that.
Because I was on a work permit.
I don't want to put up with this stuff in
the things that I do in my free time, I don't
think I am alone there.
This is part of being fair, and this is part
of being a good community.
Values.
If your project is values based you can community
them and bring values back to them I have
some examples.
First call request project it's to help people
make their first contribution to open source
software so control it makes contributing
to open source impossible.
Reward, you get to be someone who has contributed
to open source.
Community, it's designed to support you as
you do that.
Fairness, it's about making open source more
accessible to people who historically have
been left out and values, this open source
software, this idea that we all use it, we
should all get back to it.
Model view culture, it's a critique focused
on tech They solicit contributions for the
community and people write for it.
Control, you decide what you write about.
Rewards, they actually pay writers which is
it's very rare to get paid for you writing
so I feel like for me it's always been that
I got paid to write rather than how much money
I made from it.
Community.
This publication is a contribution to the
community that cares about inclusivity in
tech and fairness.
This is the whole aim of social justice, right,
regardless of whatever game are spouting now.
You see in every issue in every article.
Their final example is technically speaking
it's an newsletter that a friend and I
run we try to encourage people in there public
speaking.
So our goal or pitch is like we're like the
mentor that shows up in your in box every
week saying you have something to say, and
here is some resources that might be helpful.
Control, it's all about making things seem
more possible, kind of demystifying things.
Reward, you know, maybe you get to come somewhere
like this right and share whatever it is that
you have been excited about on stage.
You get to be a public speaker.
Community, so we run webinars most months,
we engage with people on Twitter, we take
questions find the resources that they need.
Fairness.
So part of this is about demystifying this
process and this idea you don't need to be
chosen that you can put yourself forward.
We highlight things like travel costs because
we think that transparency there makes things
fairer.
Values, this is the last one but it's a really
big one fours.
Like I said we think conferences should cover
travel costs, we weigh that in what CFPs we
include, we also believe in inclusive events.
We will only share things with a code of conduct.
I am not going to pretend that a code of conduct
is a high bar of inclusivity it's a new minimum
it's pretty telling when events don't have
one.
More broadly than that we curate this vision
of the tech industry that we wish we saw,
we share at least 50% content from women we
actively look for other under-represented
groups to highlight and include.
So if you are feeling a little burnt out I
want to leave you with the question I asked
earlier.
What if you expected more from your side projects
and less from your job?
More broadly I want to ask what if we as a
community as asked more from our side projects
and less from our jobs.
I am really happy that I got to share this
talk at JSConfEU I know yarn and Tiffany and
the other organisers work super hard to make
it that kind of space so thank you so much
for having me.